Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel me and my son Nathan we're
spending the next six days exploring
Spain we're going to be catching
enormous catfish
camping exploring castles and having an
amazing adventure and we're bringing you
along for the ride
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Spain well it's 10 30 a.m local time and
we are exhausted but we're gonna hit the
road we've got about two and a half
hours of driving to do and uh we gotta
find some food along the way as well
foreign
and I am hungry so we're gonna try to
get some food you awake Nathan
you're doing great but we're actually
lucky we found a restaurant everything
closes for the afternoon Siesta here in
a little bit so uh I'm gonna try to grab
some food before all the business is
shut you know Nathan in the afternoons
everyone takes a little nap and a break
and they call it a siesta
yeah I'm exhausted that sounds amazing
this game there you go it looks like we
got eggs Spanish ham and french fries
got a big Supermarket right here we're
gonna pop in and grab some supplies real
quick
the sunscreen
that's water resistant
look at that Nutella biscuits oh cured
ham chocolate look at this 59 cents for
a baguette yes some ham and a fresh
baguette my favorite snack in all of
Spain
well that worked out pretty well and I
even remembered how to say where is the
bathroom in Spanish that turned out to
be very useful didn't it
ready we had emergencies
doing a city called riba Roya de ibre
which I think means the Red banks of the
Ebro River
you may not realize this but this is me
and Nathan's second trip to Spain about
three years ago me and him did a
father-son trip here to the Ebro River
to catch massive carp so we're coming
back and doing the same trip over again
but this time we're gonna try to go for
massive 100 plus pound catfish if you
guys want to see the video of our first
trip to Spain I'll put a link in the
video description below
the landscape here in Spain reminds me a
lot of New Mexico or Arizona and the U.S
it's just really pretty
your destination is on the left all
right you ready buddy
well how you doing Harry you're growing
up a lot oh wait oh we're here at Nick
shattuck's house and we are gonna go and
drive down and meet him at the river
boys hop into the car
[Applause]
okay
good to see you again
guys welcome to the Ebro River this is
an amazing fishery it's got some of the
biggest catfish in the world it's a
great carp fishing River also has Xander
which is like walleye we're going to be
targeting massive Wells catfish a giant
eel-like catfish it gets over 200 pounds
huge a huge sack of catfish bait right
there
see these big pellets they're made with
like fish meal and stuff and this is
what we catch this massive catfish on
they'll go and just Chum pounds and
pounds of these out in the water that
right there is the typical rig we use
when we're fishing for Wells catfish we
got a sturdy but small hook with a hair
rig on it go and you pierce them onto a
little needle you thread them on to the
end of a hair rig so you have a big
chunk of bait for the catfish to Target
here in Spain they're not allowed to use
lead fishing weights anymore so they use
River Rocks and they attach them to
their line using these rubber band
harnesses to strap in a river rock or a
bit of concrete with his rubber band
then you paddle it out with the boat and
drop it overboard it's just like shark
vision
only giant catfish all right there you
go
oh one of the guys just got a big take
on their car parts the alarm went off
right in there oh that cart popped off
it looked like it was somewhere between
25 to 30 pounds but that's a really
common sized carp here in the Ebro River
foreign
I think Nathan's falling in love with
Spanish Yoo-hoo well it's about five
o'clock and the Spanish Siesta has ended
so the tackle shop should be opened back
up and uh we're gonna go pick up some
fishing gear real quick
there you go Bud
all right
all right we're gonna pick up some
groceries here at the grocery store
this is a specialty Salted Pig leg that
they do here in Spain and it is so
delicious look at these are like little
cookies
there we go well I think I think we
should probably get two because we
already went through an entire case in
one day so you know
you wanna try this
um leche and Pera this is whole milk
it'll be warm are you okay with warm
milk
you want to try some JoJo Crema all
right
you want to try ham flavored potato
chips
yeah you want to try some of these okay
all right we're back here we got the
rods out just listen waiting now
not too bad
oh yeah
oh there we go there we go oh yeah oh
nothing just jump I've never seen a
catfish jump
straight up look at that
look at that holy mackerel right after
that
that is huge
yeah that takes some pressure off real
quick your PB fish already look at that
look right here guys this is a Wells
catfish this is a beautiful evil River
Wells catfish
I'm trying to be a professional yeah
it's a nice one night you want yeah this
thing is about six foot three inches six
foot two inches 191 centimeters and then
125 pounds what a beast right off the
bat
Nathan
Hey kid
[Music]
that's right
this thing's huge
these things are eating machines
look at that
my first Evo Wells catfish and that's
why people come all the way to Spain to
fish for these that was awesome but now
I need to make sure Nathan gets to land
the next one
yeah yeah
so we're just reeling in the rods and
rebating everything just because there's
a lot of weed floating down the river
it's coming up the lines and the pellets
dissolve about after three hours or so
so we just kind of freshen them up
we're just sitting here watching the sun
go down and Nick's over here preparing a
curry and this is this is the life
look at the yellow fat on that chicken
breast
method
all right sun setting I can get all my
lights out so we can film
I've got two 1000 Lumen bicycle lights
attached to a double GoPro Mount we're
gonna light this place up
now we get a catfish we could see what's
going on check it out we got a big
creepy Spanish spider down here
oh yeah see she's got all her babies on
her back that's all her babies see
gorgeous wow look at that thing
look at this check this out we got a
nice pile of Curry here just watching
our fishing rods
oh that's nice hey did you like the
curry yeah
[Music]
see you guys
well we finished up dinner and Nick's
family's heading back to the house and
me and Nathan are just sitting here by
the rod seeing if we can't pull another
fish out tonight
did you have a fun day Nathan
[ __ ] snake
I'll tell you what guys we slept about
10 hours last night and it felt so good
is such perfect camping weather the fall
in Spain is lovely
no action on the rods last night which
apparently is not too uncommon for the
catfish
Sun's getting up over the horizon and
we're just baiting up the rods and
getting them back out there
all right now we got the rods out we can
do a little breakfast here
let's
oh
that's pretty good
[Applause]
real and then these look like little
chocolate Fritos they kind of taste like
a then are you gonna drink some
chocolate milk with your chocolate
cereal yes
tell you what it's sure nice sitting in
the shade of this overpass it just makes
it the perfect temperature
all right all right come on ride ride
the bar
oh he's getting close Nathan he's
getting close
yeah I can see him
look at this
that's it come on put it up are you
doing it
it's always about 35 40 pounds that's
your first Wells catfish you want to
come here check it out I
don't know so check it out this is a
Wells catfish they look a lot like the
American catfish except for the back
half of their body is like an eel they
got this fin that just comes all the way
from here all the way down allows them
to swim forward and back and make some
really powerful on this one yeah
what's that a minute all right that's it
Nathan they look like you're holding it
all right
there you go
he's off Nathan what do you think of
your first Wells catfish it was big did
he pull hard yes what do you think
harder your 38 pound flat head or this
Wells catfish the wells catfish well we
got a fish on the bank now we gotta
rebate our Rod to get them on back out
there
oh all right we're rebate it up now
we're gonna sit and wait so we can't get
another one you guys did you guys find a
persimmon tree oh look at this it's a
persimmon tree it's beautiful
that's good oh look at this oh good yeah
don't eat the skin okay
here eat the gooey part
that's pretty good isn't it you've never
had a persimmon they're sweet very sweet
and they taste like honey and cinnamon
one of my favorite fruits Nathan you
hungry
you want some pot noodle another hasta
there we go
all right we're gonna try some of these
little Spanish cookies
I think this one's lemon flavored
I like those this is Hoya ladra I don't
know what hoilateral flavor is but look
at that
oh that's kind of like a really fluffy
pie crust with the powdered sugar on the
outside
Harry and Nate are singing the
catfishing song
oh
all right got ourselves a nice little
pepperoni pizza now Pizza is one of
those foods you can find everywhere in
the world and everywhere you go it's
just a little bit different look at the
crust on that man that's that's like a
cracker that is that's like crunchy
I like it though good there you go you
can handle that that's two hands buddy
the dog's waiting for you
oh
God
oh that was exciting against the blood
going only got a few cranks into him and
the hook pulled out those fishing show
all right Nick brush your teeth up by
getting ready for bed
all right guys I finally got Nathan to
bed and I'm gonna go to sleep too I'm
I'm
but we got rods in the water and I'm
just gonna kind of keep the door open
and keep an ear out for him and we'll
see what happens
well guys it was kind of quiet last
night I didn't get any bites on the
catfish rods
um Nick was down there and working some
car prods and landed a 35 pounder well
me and Nate are a little bit low on
breakfast Supply so uh we're gonna go
pop into the supermarket and see what we
can get
you want some ham always yeah we always
need ham
we got this one this one's like a little
bit of everything
you want this one okay we're gonna get
some bananas uh number 72 number 72
right gives us a little sticker with our
price ready to buy them
thing groceries are so cheap here in
Spain we've got a loaf of bread for I
think 80 cents a half a gallon of milk
was 99 Cents and most of that's because
the US dollar is so strong right now
when you go overseas everything's on
sale
come come over here you know people you
want to try one of these bad boys well
chocolate croissants are awesome
we're having sugar with our sugar here
with a side of sugar
the pellets that we're using for bait
probably all dissolved by now so I'm
gonna reel in the rods get the Seaweed
off them and we'll get fresh baits out
there
the boys are playing a Spanish game
called bocce ball you throw a little
white ball out on the lawn and try to
see who can get their ball closest to it
though it keeps turning into a wrestling
match in the dirt
no
they seem to be having a really good
time
that's a Spanish ham sandwich right
there
so good
Spanish walnuts here I'm
Pokemon foshikitos here sampling the
health food of Spain here
this tastes a lot like a ding dong it
will just wipe off
[Laughter]
so let me see
well guys the sun is set and it has been
a fabulous time but we have got to get
to Barcelona we've got some fun stuff we
want to do and see in the city and uh so
we're gonna drive down there tonight but
we've had a great time and we did
exactly what we set out to do I caught a
catfish over 100 pounds and Nathan got a
reel in a Wells catfish well Nick thank
you so much we had such a great time so
wanted to get a big catfish and you put
us right on one right off the bat it was
awesome all right Nathan I think we need
to get in the car all right guys thanks
for having us
safe travels to Barcelona man hey thank
you
all righty let's go get checked into our
hotel
you gotta put your card to make the
lights work
there's all the batteries we need to
charge I got my charging station all set
up but me and Nathan are hungry should
we go get some food yeah yeah all right
let's do it well it's about 11 30 p.m
and I'm out with my seven-year-old we're
gonna see if we can't find somewhere to
eat
Nathan you want some kebabs yeah let's
do it there you go there's your burger
buddy
shawarma it's like a middle eastern
burrito fabulous
hey you like that pastry crust and honey
and pistachio nut is so good
that was good buddy all right guys I'm
putting the camera down I gotta get
Nathan to bed and we are gonna be doing
a ton of sightseeing tomorrow better get
some sleep see you in the morning
good morning
when you see me get up and get some
breakfast
all right let's do it
well welcome to Barcelona it's our first
look at the city in the daytime
and uh they sure do like their spray
paint here yeah look at that one I think
I got all sorts of spray paint on that
yeah see look how he signed it all these
storefronts have these roll down steel
covers and every single one of them's
got spray paint on it some of it's nice
some of it's not
that was a good job too look at that
this guy's got talent
yeah as the stores open up they'll roll
up these metal grates and then you won't
see it anymore
this is a little this is a Spitfire
Spanish pocket knives
look at this place this is a massive
flea market it's here every weekend in
Barcelona and we're gonna try to find
some souvenirs for a mom and our
brothers and stuff
watches cheap knives
well that's nice and metal too that's
oh this place is huge
look at this there's a Spanish Pokemon
cards
hey did you happy yeah look at that
that's a crazy Bakugan we gotta we got a
gift for Jacob too much
that's a good souvenir for Jacob
look at that so you get that for Mama
okay
it's for Tommy he loves World War II
stuff I just found this World War II
Africa Court Nazi helmet for sale
gonna blow his mind
oh this Spanish weather has been amazing
you want you want to get one
do you like that
oh that's good that's like the best
little slushie I've ever had
trienza
it's kind of like a fruitcake and a
Danish had a baby you ready everybody
I'm lucky to still have my fingers
got little Spanish knives southern
France and Spain they have a tradition
of eating with your own pocket knife so
there's like little Spanish eating that
I kind of want to get one all right take
it out take that to dinner and you eat
with it
oh that is the sangrada Familia started
in 1880 still not finished so this is
like one of the main tourist attractions
here in Barcelona so you can see it is
crowded you have to get tickets to go
inside but they'll let you go up to the
top of the tower and see a cool view of
the city it's a giant gothic church look
at every square inch of it just covered
in ornate decorations very Gothic well
we've been doing a lot of walking so I
think we're gonna grab a taxi and just
have them give us a little tour of
Barcelona
I've been there
yeah we're just gonna kind of drive
around for an hour and see the city and
it's nice way to kind of relax and still
do the tours thing
Nathan's super jazzed to go through his
Pokemon cards we got like four stacks of
these for like ten dollars
so this is the Barcelona Football Club
Stadium so apparently a really popular
soccer team
is where they used to do the bull fights
now we drive past all the Olympic
stadiums from the Barcelona Summer
Olympics
statue of Christopher Columbus
I'll tell you what that was an awesome
idea only about 35 dollars it was
cheaper than doing the hop-on hop-off
bus I'll tell you what me and Nathan
we're going to try getting some paella
here we're gonna go to lunch oh
I don't know if you've ever had a green
olive before
no
that is the fanciest Fanta ever
I was kind of a [ __ ] I ordered a meat
paella instead of a traditional seafood
paella but that's I'm sharing with
Nathan so you know
it's very hot okay oh look at this you
want some chicken see these are some
chicken legs and there's some rice
yeah this is really good
oh yeah is that good
that was fabulous that was really good
oh look at this
thank you
oh that's good
it's like a cream-filled gyro you Dunkin
rich dark chocolate
oh Mom can't use the dipping sauce
well that's not bad that's pretty warm
I think that's warmer than Hawaii
well me and Nate are heading back to the
hotel here because it is Siesta time
after eating all that paella we need to
take a break I'm tired are you tired
Nathan yeah we'll take a little siesta
get our energy up and later this
afternoon we'll do more exploring two
hours later Nathan should we get up and
do stuff
oh oh I like siestas if you want to go
swimming
it is
it's only like 68 70 degrees right now
it's not that hot
we'll take care of that yeah
let's see if we can find a taxi here
all right thanks have a good day
all right me and Nathan are just running
around trying to pick up a few last
minute souvenirs for my youngest son and
my wife so we're just gonna hit a few
stores
look at that is made out of Legos they
have an ice cream shop and a toy store
geez should we get that for Jacob yeah
all right we'll get this for Jacob all
right I think we got gifts for everybody
get in you want to go see a castle
thank you
buddy
all right this is Castile de monzik I
didn't pronounce that right anyway it's
a castle we're gonna check it out
so apparently this Castle was built back
in the 1600s and then it was torn down
and rebuilt again in the 1700s and it
was even used by Napoleon during the
Napoleonic Wars when the French came and
occupied Spain and uh then it was even
used by Franco during the Spanish Civil
War right before World War II all these
guns cover the harbor there shoot any
ships that try to land
foreign
[Music]
perfect thank you very much you know
Spain really is a country of night owls
after a siesta everyone's ready to stay
up late and you'll see kids and families
with small kids out at nine ten o'clock
at night on a weekend it's really
interesting
anymore
I'm gonna have nightmares for a whole
week
pick it up take out the fountain
yeah you got that
so for about two hours every night they
have the fountains with all the lights
and the music and everything it's it's
kind of nice
it's pretty cool but this place is
crowded look at this
this is fun magic day hey Nathan was
that cool yeah
hey Nathan you want to get a gelato all
right let's do it so we're gonna get
some Italian gelato this is not ice
cream people this is gelato and it is
really good
[Music]
yeah if you like gelato better than ice
cream yeah
yeah I like ice cream but I love gelato
Oh What a Night on the town
[Music]
yeah I've never been to I think that is
the first time I've ever come into my
hotel and there was a DJ spitting
records in the lobby
all right guys it is 10 30 at night and
time to hit the sack I'm gonna get him
to bed and I will see you guys bright
and early in the morning
food and go to church
and it is absolutely quiet out on the
streets this Sunday morning which is one
of the nice things about having a city
of night owls
you get up early you have the place to
yourself
all right we're here I think we better
put the camera down I'll see you guys in
a little bit so Nathan how was church
did you understand anything no well it's
fun to get to spend some time with some
local people I think it was a good
experience for Nathan to see what it's
like to be somewhere where you don't
speak the language I think it's good for
everyone to experience that at least
once or twice well we made it back to
the hotel and we are exhausted and so
we're gonna take it easy kind of pack up
a little bit because it's our last full
day and we've got to get out bright and
early tomorrow morning
my Pakistani burrito I love you so much
Shawarma always seeing it he's just
watching well Nathan have you had a good
day yes me too we had a lot of big plans
but in the end we just took it easy and
it's been wonderful
[Music]
thank you
hey
boys I missed you what's up Nathan did
you have a good trip yeah I said I hope
you guys at home enjoyed watching this
as much as me and Nathan enjoyed doing
it if you guys want to see more videos
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
make sure to click subscribe we put out
new videos every Saturday morning and
check out our travel Adventure playlist
where all of our travel Adventures
alright guys I'll see you next Saturday
morning click subscribe if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching